Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welco-  no... I di- I- oh, I'm EUAEGH
Why, I.. UAGHH
I ca- UGH, I don't even have it... Agh God cock
I'm not ready for- uh... You, you- HA! God damnit! God, just get in my hand, Ehh Welcome back to Fruit Ninja! Now..
Well FUCKING... Really?
Ok.. Alright then. So, Fruit Ninja is a game that I played um,
It's actually one of the last games that I played while I had the Vive back in my old place
Um, and it's something that I left behind because it was so unbelievably frustrating
But now that I got the wireless setup
I think it's gonna be way better because I'm gonna be way good-er at it
Cuz that's words that use good, so here we goOOo!
Now I don't want to play classic mode. Classic mode is for dumb babies who- who like things old
which is why people watch me! Blam! Okay, so let's.. That- Wher are y- where are y- hello?
Aagh!
Got 'em
Well didn't mean to do that... WEUUAHU
I got you. I got you. Huah
HiYAH, oh-yah, oh yes, ya-ya woo!
Here we go. This is the shit! That's what I like!
AAAaAaghhhhhHHHHEY!
YES! YES! YEEEAASSS!
YEEEEASSSS! YES!
EAUAgh-AY
Hey! Ho!
Yes, okay, well the music stopped now, and I feel a lot of- lot less excited about what was happening.
Ah, didn't mean to do that, did not- oh, shoot! Shooty toots!
I got two seconds!- Well, that two seconds amounted to absolutely dick diddly... But!
Not- oh, that's terrible.
Oh, that was an awful score. I did awfully.
Aw. Okay, something tells me I didn't capitalize on my...
Combo, but that's not why I'm here! The mode that I actually like
is survival, because survival
offers challenge and
rewards skill, of which I have numerous amounts of- hang on one second - just shut up- there we go.
Little quieter. Okay, alright, and as everyone knows, I have
gratuitous amounts of skill.
N- stop laughing.
So the trick of this one yeah, you can't get 3 X-
You can't miss three times, but you get bonuses depending on how you don't miss. WHOA! Hey, calm down there, Titty Sprinkles
It's the first round.
Uuuuuuuh!
I'm gonna get you. You think you're gonna get me? The answer's you're NOT!
And I hate you.
Ooh, ah, get'em, get'em! Oh
What up?
Hey- yah! Hoy, yah! Huhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhungh
Hey, yo, hey, yeah
Yuh!
Whoa- yeah, ah shit ah frick, missed one. That's okay
because...
BECAU- Oh well. That's not good. Oh
Ha got him. Because every hundred you get a freebie
Whoa Oh also that happens
WOOO!!!
Got a freebie yeah, yeah
Yeah! Whoa.
Oh
shitty dicks Unh!
Got him
You can't beat me. WHAT~?
Who the Frick frack a titty Winkle? Alright I'm gonna get you. This is the game that gets me frustwated
Cuz I just like- I keep going for it no matter what I'm like always
always
Pushing myself to new limits cuz I'm so good at what I do, and I'm amazing.
...ebh.
Hiya. I'm a ninja don't you believe me? About how ninja-ing I am? Hooao!
What you got nothing? Oh, yeah?
*soft orgasm*
Uh, bjoink, not today
not tomorrow not
On Sunday! Eat shit. And by shit I mean fruit.
Cuz I'd really hate to think- AUOGH! all this fruit was going to waste. You know- whoa. Hey whoa low blow!
Asshole, oh, this is a lot of waste to be perfectly honest
What how?
On whose authority?
Shit shit. Okay. Is ahh freebie
Euie!
Do a little dance
cut a little fruit. Boink!
Get down tonight, huh?
no, okay, ah
Stop. Being. A douche.
Not today, I think I got all of that. Anytime I actually think I'm doing good. I'm actually missing completely
WUH! WOOH!
Kiwi! All right come on. I've got a whole lot more if you got a whole lot more on your end
Let's see who's got more on this unlimited fruit planet. Hiyah.
You know, we could solve all the world's hunger, but you guys choose to throw it at me, and I just have to defend myself
Aiyah, oh, yeah
Yes! Uh-oh- I'M BLIND! No! NO I went BLIND! No you deserve to die! No, I was blind...
NOOOOO!!!
Goddamnit
I was doing totally fine. *sigh* alright come on. Let's see what you got, no?
Pah... ouh-
Got him
Shunk! just throw them onto my sword
Shit never mind alright. I'm gonna try-hard this one so no jokes. No jokes, everybody shut up.
Oh,
Oh!...Oh.
Come on faster faster come on
I wish there was like an extreme setting, not that I could handle that, I'd probably died right
away anyway, but just 'cause- for my own ego. Come on, you think you can do this? You think you do- AHH!
Where'd it go?! damn It. You think you can do that to me? The answer is yes obviously, but I don't like it. Wh- hence the complaining
Who?
What!? No, what the hell?...
Damn you!
No, God- really?
Really, ah give me that freebie. I need it. Oh, I mean, I don't NEED it, but I quite obviously NEED it. There we go
okay, can't miss one.
AHH!
No! DICKHOLE! DICKHOLE! Okay? Well I'm building back. Noh!
Wha- No- NOOOOO!!!
God dingus damn me to fuck hell. Why does it keep? Why do I keep going? I'm blind
I can't see a thing. Why? Why does it keep going blind like that?
It must be like the wireless thing. It's a little janky. It's not quite a hundred percent perfect. I mean don't get me wrong
It's really cool. Well. What the hell. It's really cool, but also
It's not perfect
This is the one game on Vive that'll actually get me sweaty, so
*sharp exhale*
Probably just more from the anger than from the actual like athleticism of it. I'm doing worse than ever
I'm never gonna beat that high score ever in my life
WHOA! Whoa whoa whoa, Sonny Jim, whoa whoa whoa, eat a tick
NGAUH!
What the hell? My tracking went off. Ah!
This wireless thing, it's messing up my score. It's really cool and fun and all, but my score!
Whoa (x7), easy.
Easy there, Sonny Jim.
Come on! (x6)
You think you can? You think you CAN? Well I'M here to tell you that you CANNOT!
Woo! (x3)
What? No.
Yes, yep, yep-a-rooni. Nope-a-roni. Bee-omp! Wimpo! Flompity! A-GUAMP! Nooo...
Wow, that Markiplier, he's so handsome and skilled and great at cutting fruit. He's a real PROVIDER!
He's a provider of entertainment AND sustenance
What a MAN! What- oh come on.
What a man.
No! (x8) Not today! I'm just getting to the good part.
Where are you going? Where are you going, friend? Where are you going?
Nahh! (x3) N-Oh COME ON!!!
Whoa- how- what? dude, I'm alive?! how am I alive? I don't understand that entirely, but I'm okay with it.
Hah.
Aye-yai-yai.
Blaugh... Ahh.
H-NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!
*grunt sigh*
All right. that is that. I love this game, but I hate this game
Do you understand the complex emotion that have to go through a man's body to be able to comprehend something of that nature?
I think not. so anyway, that is fruit ninja. I like it a lot.
Maybe I'll save this for a stream someday because this is just a casually fun kind of game, so thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought down the comments below and uh, as always, I will see YOU in the next video...
Buh~bye!!!
["Crazy La Paint" by Minimusicman]